Hey guys
A few months ago I brought you a video in which
I introduced the possibility of Littlefinger's death
for the upcoming season which would according to my theory happen on his own wedding night.
However, this same theory might have been confirmed by a recently published behind-the-scenes photos.
As I already brought the ten minutes long detailed video about this theory, today, I'll try to explain it to you
as short as possible. This theory of mine starts with Peter Baelish who did all he could to set Sansa as a queen of the north.
Littlefinger betrayed Ned stark in order to set up a fight between wolves and lions and then poisoned Jeoffrey on his own wedding night to save Sansa
and then that same girl, already tortured by the Lannisters, handed over to an even more sick oppressor, Ramsey Bolton
all in order to turn the North against the Boltons, and to give him an opportunity to lead the knights of the Vale
who he is commanding with by manipulating young Lord Robyn which he provided by killing Robyn's father and mother
all in order to set Sansa as the queen in the North.
As we saw by his face expression in the season 6 finale, Littlefinger, he did not expect that Jon, who is not even near house Stark
would be proclaimed King of the North by other Northern Lords
and as we saw in his face expression that's also the moment in which he started making a new plan.
His new plan involves Sansa as his wife as a wife with who he will manipulate as he is manipulating Robyn
which would provide him the northern army and would lead him one step further to conquering the iron throne
His plan by this theory is trying to make a conflict between Jon Snow and the north
or to arrange Jon's death but also to make sure that this time he will get the northern army which marrying Sansa will assure
as they named it, "The White Wedding", between Sansa and Peter Baelish will happen upon Littlefinger's threat to Sansa
that he will pull the Vale troops back to the Vale unless Sansa marries him while Jon Snow and his force will not be able to follow
Jon will be at Dragonstone
Of course the first thought you have right now probably is even if he would want to
Littlefinger could not command the lords and the knights of the Vale
but be careful about it and remember what happened in the 4th episode of the 6th season
Don't forget that the knights of the Vale were mobilized not only because of Peter but only because of his
relation towards Lord Robyn.
If some of the lords from the Vale such as Jon Royce the lord of Runestone were then to disobey Peter's commands
they would be sentenced to death by the Lord of the Vale by Lord Robyn Arryn,
by the lord who is manipulated and does as Peter says
All the lords from the Vale are vessels of House Arryn, and have to do as Lord Robyn commands
or otherwise they would be executed.
Before I go any further you have to know that at this point
Sansa will not be alone in Winterfell, there will be her brother Bran at her side who will finally arrive home
the first episodes of the seventh season, while her sister Arya will also arrive at Winterfell a bit later.
With emotional scenes between Arya, Bran, and Sansa,
there will also come to the problem that the differences between the Stark sisters
which will eventually result in  Peter Baelish taking advantage of and increasing those differences
it will conflict between those sisters.
Arya has always had more rigid cold while Sansa has learned to be more pragmatic.
Arya is a skilled killer and wants revenge immediately
while Sansa has a more subtle and manipulative way of doing things
which she learned from Littlefinger and Cersei as well.
Having developed very different perspectives, Arya and Sansa will clash in a matter of ruling.
Upon noticing the split between these sisters
Peter Baelish will take his chance to take advantage of the certain situation by increasing conflict between Arya and Sansa
which will not end as Peter Baelish wants.
According to linked plot, Bran Stark will help his sisters to see through Littlefinger's game
which will result in Sansa sentencing Baelish to death and with Arya carrying out this same sentence.
But let's get a little bit back
As I was saying, Littlefinger will start his new plan by marrying Sansa
but at the same time he will not be aware that Sansa is manipulating him
that Sansa and Arya have found out the truth about his betrayal of their father which they will most probably find out from the Hound.
as they brotherhood without banners is headed north.
There's also a possibility that Stark sisters will find it out from their brother Bran, as it's easy to assume that
Bran will most likely enter a vision and go to the day of Ned's arrest
in order to find out who betrayed his father which would provide his clear answer
However, while there are a lot of possibilities about how the Starks will find out the truth
there is no doubt that they will finally find out in the seventh season.
That's the moment when the wedding between Sansa and Peter is going to happen.
The moment which will lead to their wedding night, which is orchestrated by the Stark sisters
, by Sansa and Arya
As this theory continues, Littlefinger and Sansa after the wedding feast will go to their room
and while they are alone and while Baelish thinks that  his cunning skills and his genius mind
again resulted in the Starks being manipulated, in that very moment Sansa will put a dagger down Littlefinger's throat